on the same day that survivors of the
Florida School massacre raise their
voices and protests the gunman returned
to court and said not a word
the court accepted a not guilty plea
from Nicholas Cruz yesterday but his
lawyers say he is ready to spend the
rest of his life in prison Manuel
Bojorquez was at the hearing he's
outside Marjory Stoneman Douglas High
School in parkland with the latest on
this story man well good morning good
morning we are learning more details
about the police response to the
shooting here from new 911 released
yesterday
Nicholas Cruz faces 34 counts of
premeditated and attempted murder and
prosecutors say they will seek the death
penalty even though the judge entered a
not guilty plea
Nicholas Cruz's own public defenders
left little doubt he was the gunman mr.
Cruz is willing to enter a plea of
guilty
prosecutors rejected that offer at
Marjory Stoneman Douglas high school
some students say they want the 19 year
old killer to live the rest of his life
in prison it's just 2 times it's too
easy he needs two on Wednesday the Coral
Springs Police Department released 911
calls it received from inside the school
dispatchers tried to keep survivors calm
and safe he'd buy a room to everyone be
quiet ok the FBI could have and should
have done more to investigate the
information it was provided prior to the
shooting in Washington deputy FBI
director David Bowditch admitted the
agency mishandled tips about the gunman
including a call from a woman close to
Cruz who said quote he's going to
explode if the FBI had followed up on
that tip it would most likely have sent
agents to interview the shooter Ryan
petty lost his daughter Elena in the
shooting the senseless murder of so many
including my own beloved daughter Elena
test the limits of faith and demands
more endurance than we thought possible
later today police may release body
camera video from the shooting including
footage from the former school resource
officer Scott Peterson who authorities
say did not enter the building during
the attack Peterson has defended his
actions saying he thought the shooting
was happening outside Nora
Manuel thinks it's so difficult to hear
from the parents and I keep thinking
about how hard it is for the parents to
see how much authorities how much of a
head up heads up that they knew that
this guy clearly had had issues yeah
heartbreaking the more you hear the
worse it is the worse it has I agree